jam own Eric Brennan is is all bunched
up because his team England lost now his
mother is actually from England born and
raised bro so as as Italian as he looks
or as as Latin as he looks to be my
older brother yeah you guys click it for
real like God when I saw you guys
walking the arocs a big kid and I
thought to myself you guys could be
related right
you got damaged he's my brother tone
underneath there that I don't know if I
Eric wouldn't be the athletic one what
air all day we go no Eric would be the
wise one and he'd be your older brother
and he'd go like this he his role would
be like this hey settled now jam on it
let's take it Eric's a wise dude yeah
I'm the moral compass of people's
relationship yes you're you're a bee I
feel like you're the man who breathes
sense into the mob like the group is
like let's go brought that back brother
I don't know I've sent you here Eric Oh
guys yeah Obama said I'm the consigliere
I'm Frank from the Godfather you know I
mean I'm the one that's like I'm not a
wartime consumer guide yeah I'm gonna
say let's go talk to him well when
they're when they're going through who
they're gonna take out yeah who who
needs to die cuz the cops are caught a
bunch of them and then we go and they go
what about what about Mickey gee he's a
soldier marine not a shot at a turn and
then you go like this then again that's
it yeah so I'm the one that he gets the
guy practically you're practically that
guy right rather be that guy because
when I forget you sure I was doing
Aubrey Marx's he was if this movie 300
you're like you know people think you're
like a Leonidas someone well you're
wrong sir I'm the guy with the eye patch
who's gonna tell go and store you die
you you I don't want to fight I'm gonna
run back and tell you is that's actually
you you have the capacity to fight and
get deep and dark and dirty but you're
right you are a guy who I feel like
would be more on the you know strategic
like us what would you know you let me
know you want me to say because I'm
gonna go back to town while you boys
fight this war every group has a
somebody
that my buddy Larry Mikado and when we
were younger he would always like [ __ ]
would be going on like dude to be
wrestling high school throwing [ __ ]
somebody's gonna get hit with something
right or somebody's getting flipped on
their back and break something whatever
and it'd be all this kind of [ __ ] going
on and you'd see Larry and I swear to
god he was not a big guy and he would
you just see just the top of his just
his eyeglasses and hit need more glasses
he behind the couch just watching
everything but he always had a shield
crazy noise and something yeah you don't
meet a lot of Larry's Larry Makara
that's such an old school name and the
kids Larry I never was a fighter see
it's interesting you and I because you
are a big guy so you're six four yeah
you're a big guy so you've always had to
fight you know you didn't you didn't
fight I'm saying you didn't have to
fight because when you're a big guy you
don't necessary fight but you got into
fighting correct you know for me I'm a
big guy and I've never been in lighting
fights I don't I've never I don't even
in like three fights my whole life and
it's just because you're like you know I
don't know if I want to mess with that
guy but sure that's with me I feel like
those people though right like most
people haven't been on a ton of five
it's also intelligent to avoid fights
cuz there's really actually no upside I
mean I mean tell me what you'll say you
you're gonna beat me up but guess what
you're gonna get hurt cuz I'm not you
think I'm just gonna lay down my own
thing is like yeah I'm probably gonna
get demolished in this situation I'm in
right now but make sure you ready I'm
Dufresne and what to call it you might
get a couple of you gonna get me but get
on fighting that digger somebody's going
home with a vagina I'm using my mouth
but that's that's probably why you're
funny cuz I feel like if you can kill
him with humor you can get out of fights
I was I'm mister like hey let's talk
about this you know but I take as a
story one time I was I was pulling into
a 7-eleven
and this sort of skinhead biker bald
head guy with the mustache and tattoos
all over you know I almost hit him and
he looked at me like you know he was
like you mother you know I was like hey
sorry bro sorry I parked but when I
walked in he was standing
they're in line and he locked eyes with
me like word he locked eyes with me like
oh I'll kill your black ass that type of
thing
and I locked eyes back in my mind I was
like don't break I cut and like I was
like oh my god what if I don't break eye
contact what's gonna happen and then he
looked away from me and I as I passed a
mile and oh my god sorry I just got
sorry I would I'd already said sorry I
already had like a you know god
another time almost hit a guy I was
backing up I hate pedestrians because
they think they own this is a three ton
vehicle bro but I thinks about half this
is gonna kill you guys
I don't care what the goddamn government
says about you have the right away you
should be looking at what's going on so
the guy wasn't moving you know he's a
mover big burly blue-collar mover guy I
almost hit him he splits my car he's
like I can't when he's going on and on
and I said hey relax I'm sorry there you
go
it's okay bad man but you know what
though I saw him though I saw him like
go from like he was ready yeah and I was
like it's cold man he's always you know
he did he would have been like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yes exactly within the
situation like why don't you [ __ ]
watch where you go and engage I just was
like you know what chill bro I is that
lie down I'll go down Pacific I've
already relaxed when you do that me too
because by the way by the way you're a
fighter not I'm not you but you can
handle yourself huh yeah you can't you
smart guide to using club works I see
Matt glove works he's only one kicking
the [ __ ] a glove works and it's a boxing
pastry chef yummy but we're working on
[Laughter]
meeting like a Billy Jack but anyways I
feel like when guys the guys that really
can handle themselves they're not making
I'm a bunch of no no and I make it right
no I remember I was at remember uh
what's that show that Adam hunter used
to run in Westwood the brew house so
there was this comedian he's on stage
when I walk into the room this communion
on stage Quran that think that's his
name anyway Tehran no not too wrong
another guy great name either way either
way he's going in on this guy in the
crowd and again a couch like shorter
than you but built you know and so they
come here come aside and we need your
help
what am I gonna do he's nothing I hate
just cuz I'm six-three you're gonna grab
me it's like I'm back at home base I'm
in the truck going like this hunt I'm
telling him where to go but anyway be
good he's yelling at a guy in a crowd
and it's getting tense but I walk up to
the guy that he's yelling at and I put
my hand on his shoulder just to be like
hey man is everything okay but I felt
rock okay I thought rock your rage like
I felt like but now look at the guy's
face and he was calm he had a little
smirk on his face but I knew that this
guy could kill everyone in the room yeah
okay
yeah so I said let me get you a beer man
you know the guy comes outside means
like problem was I said well what's up
man he's like yeah you know I'm uh I'm a
green beret or he's like Jesus
he's like I just got back you know and
I'm just I wanted to come have a good
time out here and he just was like I
just thought to myself it's like ok let
me explain it like this I go to glove
works now I'm boxing yeah I already feel
like I'm walking around knowing that
imagine if you've gone through five
years of Green Beret training yeah how
you must feel
yeah how much you must feel like
untouchable please test me well do self
alia Chris D'Elia
at the Comedy Store in the main room I'm
sorry in the in the original room how
long ago this was probably six seven
years ago by the way I got attacked in
an hour but go on so he's he code this
girl's kind of heckling Chris but Chris
was in a bad mood for another reason and
I've never seen Chris to this but he was
he was going after the gal in a way that
was a little bit like like well it's not
Chris
yeah so also also I noticed that the
gentleman sitting next to the young lady
was a very wide handsome but rugged man
and you know I you know me you caught
them and I saw the girl correct sir yeah
I clock men I I'm borderline attracted
to very very athletic you know it by the
way yeah in it and I know that it's not
gay at all there's a port of it I get us
because it's like you know you've always
wanted to be successful yeah and then
you you you find yourself going like oh
that guy looks successful yes I wonder
what he does I've always want to be a
tough guy or you recognize it you
recognize who that guy looks I've always
want to be a tough guy so when I see a
tough Kareena and you see these lines
yeah I mean you wish your line Karakas
see those funny high in in the corner
thank you you're the old mound
don't say malnourished right now you do
and I do have smile you look at those
Tom Hanks at Philadelphia somewhere
between Philadelphia and castaway like
you're ready to throw a spear I did a
fish circle and shredded this guy so
Chris is going back and I'm watching
this dude and Chris is naive
he's just naive to male aggression I'm
sorry he's I don't know what it is but I
can see that this guy is not having it
oh wow
guess what this guy's waiting at the
opening at the mouth of the door me yes
and I walked up to him Kristen Chris was
just killing her with kindness like no
he's Monica he was he was going hard on
the pain it was a little too hard
because he was in a bad mood about shoes
heckling though yeah a little bit but
then he kind of the worst huh yeah
they're the ones that go in it was it
was it was Chris was pushing it and it's
a kind of thing where if I see a guy
like that with a girl you'd be like bro
easy yeah I'm not going on I there's a
limit yeah immediately start making fun
of the guy like yeah that's the guy and
I go this is your fault correct yeah and
then he starts it cannot easily not so
with Chris so I go I said I said hey men
you know don't take that personally
because I do take it personally because
I do take it personally and you know
that's a guy who thinks he can get away
with a lot of stuff and I said I know
listenmi listenmi whatever you're
thinking about because I know and I
understand as a man you're trying to
stick up your girl none of this is worth
it and it's only downside and then he
goes did you get cuz me my friendly
gonna stomp you out yeah I said I said
oh my go what did you what did you do
you look like you fighting goes he goes
look I just got back from from Iraq you
know and I got back from my fro and he
goes and I've done my I've done my share
and I'm just trying to have a good time
but I don't like when people I don't
appreciate when people come up to my god
and I said I said and I never got it you
know me I got a dig Nagre what'd you do
what'd you do in the military I think it
looks at me and he goes
what would you vote he goes what would
you guess that's all he said he goes
what would you guess and he said he just
nodded and I went I would guess that you
are very comfortable in the violent
spaces he goes and you'd guess right so
you're gonna kill Chris right and I said
I basically said brother let me buy you
a drink and I think I told Chris but I
got him I got that guy away got him a
drink and got him away from the mall he
was waiting I did the same thing for al
Madrigal one night the first night I
ever met el man I love them he's on
stage going in on this dude all right
and it was like this kind of the guy was
a redneck he was like a like a legit
like you know you know so then al gets
off stage he hits to the booth yeah this
guy's be lining right I stepped in front
of the guy and I stepped in for an owl
and I was hey good set man
I shake his hand I just kept saying he
could that was a good set bro you did
good humans and I'm looking at him like
you know this guy behind me is about to
kick it yeah and the guy I could tell it
to guy his anger dissipated fast cuz it
does yeah like anger really like even in
the me you should learn of the mom in
the middle of something you might be
like oh I bit off a little more of my
consumer I need to get out of this
situation yes so like I've been there
it's like I got attacked in the or I got
a tire I got a guy threw a chair at me I
feel like that's the worst place to have
it happen okay so all yeah everyone can
see what's going on well I wish here's
someone know for a fact if you were
there that night this would have been a
different situation Bret Ernst were
there that night like there was no one
there there was no one there in the
crowd how long from the help me but this
was like maybe four or five years ago so
Nick Kroll goes on stage and this guy in
the back is heckling but in a way that
it was like it wasn't good spirited okay
so it's going back and forth and Nick's
trying to handle it you know wasn't it
gonna do you know what I mean he's and
he's a goofy guy so he's gonna handle it
the way he handles it so then he guy was
man come in the back like come on man
what the [ __ ] going on with just you
know so then Nick gets off station I go
on and then I'm talking I'm doing my set
a little bit and this guy says like you
know you know he said something and he
said something like wool I'd say
something right now but I was told I
can't say anything anymore go I go black
in my comedian head okay I'm going I'm
Reds owning you know yeah and I'm going
in on this dude
I know first of all let me backtrack to
say this as a comedian you're like a
fighter
you're like a kung fu expert and if
you're in a bar as a kung fu expert and
you get into a fight no matter what the
circumstance you're gonna be held
accountable because you're an expert
yeah as a comic that's your arena we are
experts at attacking breaking people
down yeah using our words as weapons
that's what I did with this thing he
didn't have he didn't have a weapon and
I got the reaction ultimately that I
wanted he be lines through the stage to
the crowd pushing people out of the way
he picks up a chair and he throws it at
me okay I block the chair and now I'm
like what is happening you know what I
mean like what so right I think up did I
pick up the chair and I throw it back at
him that right and I'm like I don't know
what's happening bro cuz I'm not a
fighter okay
and Adam egit comes he grabs the guy
he's trying to grab him and the guys in
front of the stage and I haul off and I
punch him in his jaw
okay and I'm like oh I've never hit
anybody in the face before like that has
not that what happened here is not what
happened when I just watched Mission
Impossible you know five seven Tom
Cruise punched again on the face and
that guy went through a plate-glass
without so he's out I just hit this guy
and I thought oh my god this is a
situation right now I'm like whoa bro
and so I hit him again again hit him
again I was like I was um I'm losing it
man
and so now the guy I'm trying to push
the guy out the door you know and I jump
off the stage was he you know and then
Nick Youssef yeah grabs me and he's
yelling into my ear and shaking me like
this it's not worth it it's not worth it
and it kind of was there but nobody
hears well here's what happened I
slipped out of it and now I'm looking
around the room and I'm seeing people or
like it scared they're trying to leave
and then I started to think hey there's
a show going on
there's comics about to go up after me
the waitresses aren't gonna get tipped I
swear to you these are all the things
that one on my head yeah so then I went
like whoa okay I went back onstage
I grabbed the mic and I went like this
everybody sit down you know and then
everybody's a-hole okay I got my
principal voice used to work with kids
so I know I know the register you need
to be at to make people go oh I'm so
sorry
grown man so everybody sat down I'm
bleeding my hands bleeding and in my
mind - I'm thinking god this guy almost
hit me in my face with this chair I have
to shoot tomorrow I got a 8 a.m. call
time you know I don't know I'm thinking
about other [ __ ] so I start talking
about it like what you guys let that guy
come through the crowd and get me you
guys oh I kept going there's a point of
my set watch flip back into my material
got off stage first time I ever got a
standing ovation I got off stage I was
like hell yeah that's a man [ __ ] and I
keep being funny yeah Prime Minister of
Turkey got shot in the hand they tried
to assassinate him guy shoots him he
gets caught in the hand gets shot and uh
and finishes his speech well that's you
supposed to do as a comic yeah it's a
comment you sad one up in this story and
your [ __ ] nose well I'm sway bet I
was gonna say you're worthy of my mother
punch resident bush you usually be
running Turkey you see when Bobby could
you see when Bush when they threw that
shoe at him he just goes through anyways
so yeah you know what it was cuz you're
shocked in that moment yeah you don't
know how to say if you're the President
of the United States a shoe is not
supposed to get that close to you yeah
so there's a moment when you're like
what you don't think he chewed out his
security staff if I shoe all right now
president the United States believe me
know it bit on the spot yeah you're
fired
anyways turn up the camera how do we do
that in front
everyone's okay your friend your fight
so the thing is about you really went
into it's keep on yeah there's been like
this moments like you know it's funny
they're like and when we're in the
comedy business and like we come from
all these other areas we don't know
everybody's story we don't know where
people are you know like if I was at the
Comedy Store right now and somebody was
acting up you know I would be the one
that would walk up let's say somebody's
trying to test you yeah there's some big
dude you know but we're all there you
know I would be the one that would come
up and go hey I don't know if you want
to do this right now right because this
guy you're talking to right now
he's actually been doing jujitsu for 17
years
yeah actually boxes see the guy over
there that guy used to be a UFC fighter
see this guy over there he's got an ex
punished criminal record
yeah see that guy over there you know
it's like this is our turf yeah I don't
know if you want to do this yeah and I
don't care who it is I'm not a fighter
but I get like that at the lecture
comics are a motley bunch dude I was at
the Laugh Factory one night and Dane
Cook was on stage and he was giving it
to some people and these guys work they
were so mad at him but they got up you
know and I found myself heading towards
the stage you're protecting your you
know your eternity yeah I was headed
towards the stage and I was gonna be
like wait we've all known each other
we're all gonna go down and we won't
know each other a long time look I've
known Dane I've known you I've known
I've known all you guys for I don't know
Oh more than 15 years it's pretty crazy
man
right but you also know what it takes to
get to that level like the the nerves
and nothing new material trying stuff
like I remember I was doing a show Dane
was on it and every comedian I was I was
like dead blast ago or something and
every kamini cap going back goes those
two girls in the front man those two
girls in the front two grand dangos
which once stood aside and I and you
know I don't know Dane that well he's
always been super nice to me yeah super
nice to me for a reason
and Dane goes out there I'm like I want
to watch this I wonder what he's gonna
do and he doesn't acknowledge right away
he just starts just set and they keep
shouting out and he ignores it and goes
ladies please be quiet she keeps going
this you won't you still want to do this
you want to do this and then just
[ __ ]
20 minutes yeah how many in which hand
her tits out and just he was just
[ __ ] they got them laughs he's like
what did you think was gonna happen yeah
by the way is like I've I often I it's
funny I I'm I talk about this in therapy
actually about why gets so mad onstage
when I get interrupted or there's
somebody heck up there's an anger that
comes to me that it's because it's about
injustice you know it's about what
respect it's the disrespect of it too
but at the same time like I said about
being a kung fu expert we I don't have
to attack this woman stole and I have
I'm I've been in situations where I've
said so to shake you need to stop
because you're gonna be outside crying
you know I guarantee you you're gonna be
outside crying because I first of all
I'm gonna kamikaze I'm taking this all
down suicide bomber like I'm not making
myself feel good in this situation
either so there's nothing you could say
it enough so yeah oh you're fat you're
this you're that on my cold yes go for
it cuz cuz I'm going to talk about it
myself I'm like Eminem an eight-mile I'm
rapping about like that guy dude that's
what you're gonna be I feel like I don't
know what to say you and Rosie are
similar than that cuz the same where
these girls were heckling and I wanted
to go back but you please stop it's a
it's a rattlesnake up there yeah you I
know you look super friendly cuz he's
high right now but you're gonna trigger
them and it's are a specialist call
trigger you're gonna find out she kept
going and then [ __ ] they got up
crying and laughing on Spike it works me
know what I mean man yeah you know it
works for me is I always find that they
are just they just want to be included
and they want some attention
you're the best set as far as any
community with hecklers
you're the best I'm with Eric comments
and I need a awesome new I need work out
because when someone does it I find it
so disrespectful that anger than I did
yeah I've seen you didn't have to go
yeah what I do is I do this I I
acknowledge them
III Keon uh-huh I talked to them and I
said and I say I try to figure out
what's going on now if they're drunk
they gotta get out but
I'm with but a lot of times a lot of
times they just they're just wanna be
they want to be included they're doing a
stupid lab or whatever I'll include them
I'll talk to them I'll I'll scold them
I'll go now listen to me listen to me
this is important I need you to pay
attention you're not paying attention
you're cutting up in class you're
talking and I'll kind of like bring them
back to school they usually kill it's
you number of years and they listen but
here's the thing though while that's
going on yeah it's still annoying to
everyone else right it kills the vibe
that's what I tell them though I say you
know what I love you but they're you're
bothering the people around on a ride at
Disneyland oh I got something before we
go punch last mountain yeah I know
everyone's here to see Splash Mountain
here's my story it was like shut the
[ __ ] up what are you doing right but I
have a thing like I had I had some go to
ones to some biting oh yeah oh my god I
was myself like I used to say I used to
say this is my favorite little mousetrap
I would say like they don't we're going
at it and then I would say do you wanna
have sex with me and of course the one
would be like I would never have sex and
I said then you're useless to me Dave
Attell did this a girl goes his so
offensive this girl was talking talking
food any goes I had to stop ma'am do you
have children she goes no and he goes
well then you're a failure and then Jim
Gaffigan I was doing this was 24 years
ago Jim and I I'm doing a show shitty
show in a restaurant of course and
there's a dude who's well-dressed and
he's got a mustache and he's just a
doing with them who nobody's got a he's
got a he's got this mustache and he's
he's being mean to the comics and
finally Jim Jim Gaffigan so funny right
he's so white well but he's like um
let's see I a little bit about me I'm
Korean
I'm Korea was grant was that my interest
in Asian women wouldn't be so creepy
anyway I'm in the end I know your thing
Indiana mafia hilarious right so this is
that these are it wasn't telling those
jokes this is 20 [ __ ] for you so the
guy is heckling and I I don't know why
this was so funny but chin said sir I
don't think you should be talking
because you're wearing a mustache and
the guy's like [ __ ] you Jim Hoge
acknowledged good [ __ ] you [ __ ] your
[ __ ] and obviously it clearly
smells like Bob you it wasn't from this
country who suffers i bug you because
well you can see how all the other
people are reacting so funny
julie guys and girls differently but one
time when one of my favorite guy things
i would do what if there's a guy messing
around i would say he's still going and
I'll be like guys I'm actually a
ventriloquist and my dummy is gonna talk
like so then what happens is in their
mind they go they go damn if I talk
right now I'm gonna be doing what he
says you know yes it a guy would be like
[ __ ] you and I'd be like guys my lips
didn't even move I'm drinking water
[ __ ] look out look how angry my dummy
is you know and it just it really did
they just they can't go on so you don't
get angry anymore
is this is a thing it's like I'm trying
to work on that but I had these things
about telling you you have anger issues
I the comic yes it does yeah I deal with
you know it's when I'm reading a
communication book right now and I
looked and I I gotta get my notes for a
second I'm looking at this communication
book and one of the main premises of the
book it says is about you know when
you're communicating digital don't so I
roll down
don't criticize condemn or complain with
with person you're talking to you right
yeah that is the essence of what you do
as a comedian yeah
you criticize we condemn and we complain
so I realize I need to take that just to
the stage and another thing is said in
this book is we criticize
or we complain to make ourselves feel
better yes and I realize but I realize
that is why talk about things on stage I
want to pitch about things and then I
feel better but is it but you shouldn't
do that with there's a difference though
between criticizing and being funny so
you remember Sam Brown oh no no I took
what I totally I understand what you
said I'm not I know you mean are you
saying your personal your personal
telling you what this communication book
is showing me that when you criticize
complain and condemn people that are in
your life it breeds defensiveness and
resentment so that's what they come with
scars it leaves scars ever call names
when you're in a relationship you can
you can say you can take the trash out
now I have to but when you call someone
names when you say you're a lazy piece
of [ __ ] or you're not intelligent or
that leaves scars and what my dentists
when I got married said learn how to LA
my Dennis goes learn how to fight best
advice I've ever gotten ever anywhere
and I started going to globe words and
that's why certified like physically and
Animoto not affordably learn how to
fight as in no no so I remember Sam
Brown great comic died of pancreatic
cancer no no Sam was such an amazing
comic like I like he was the first
incredible comic I'd seen when I was
first starting out like he was a closer
and a bad [ __ ] and he used to be
able to come at people like if you were
heckling him he would come up with [ __ ]
like like he'd see a guy who had spiky
hair his guy was making funny go sir if
you don't stop I'm gonna break a piece
of your hair off and stab you in the eye
with it yeah this guy what do you do for
a living a guy goes I'm a banker he goes
good now the next time you're at your
bank chaining down the Pens I'm gonna
come and make fun of you you know he was
just he had all yeah these oldies
here's my question as a sidenote to take
it another stunner my buddy Sam had two
hours and some of the most crushing
material of all time the man who died of
pink yeah no now I loved him could I
steal this could I use his jokes was
that he doing that's an ethical I just
could I borrow that's not him can I
borrow
some of his can I borrow some of his act
would it be I've never done it bad if I
die with him he's got to die with ya I
said I'm out I told him I sent him a
text because his wife read it when he
was dying I said dude I'm taking all
your material because I was like you
know but I guess not like it's like when
Ralphie died I was calling around clubs
hey I see you have an opening he would
think that was funny [ __ ] yeah well we
don't know who this guy is
countdown that's some regular white guy
that was he a famous Camino beer he was
a not a famous New York New York
headliner
yeah well there's a lot of this started
where I started in LA it was impossible
I don't know how I did it how long do la
2003 is when I really decided like oh
this is what I want to do so later start
yeah yeah at a later start yeah I was 30
when I started really yeah you know and
it was like I you know I regret that I
always regret it you know when people
say you should never grit I don't
believe in that I don't believe in not
having regrets
I think regrets are a way to not make
the same mistakes mmm
so you you should have regrets how you
deal with those regrets is the measure
of your character yep you know so
sitting around acting like things yeah I
don't believe in things happen for a
reason either I don't believe in that I
feel like we are human beings we are
adaptable yeah it's the reason why we
can live in Phoenix and we can live in
Minnesota because we adapt to things our
bodies adapt and so do our minds we you
know and so I just feel like you take
these experiences that have happened to
you and you make yourself better for it
and we need them you know Wyatt Wyatt 30
it's just because I just what I wanted
to do I was like I was like I can't I
can't just sit on my ass and be like oh
I'm gonna wake up you know I'm gonna
wake up 50 and be like how come I didn't
follow my dreams what were you doing
before I was working at a school you
know I was working at a school I was I
had a whole different life pan I was I
was going to Mount Saint Mary's College
to finish my degree I thought I was
gonna be a teacher and I was gonna do
all that and it just really wasn't like
it wasn't the thing for me you know
you've been a real success that's a big
deal like on TV now you're doing I'm
dying up here you were doing it on blunt
talk a lot of things
somewhere what I say is this is why I
have the regret that's why I worked so
hard you know I had to catch up you know
I was doing open mics with Jim Gaffigan
when I was 22 because I was like I did
but I didn't know how to do it I'm in LA
nobody's helping me out there's no older
comic coming over let me help you show
you the ropes kid no I was arrogant and
I thought I was the funniest guy in the
room
without having you up in LA yeah grew up
in LA without even knowing how to do
anything so when you were 30 what club
did you go to first oh I I was going to
like I was going all over the place I
was hitting up the Open Mic scene in LA
and then I went to like the Long Beach
they had this club called
laughes hope this weird club was between
Harry yeah it was a weird Club he was
this weird guy so I did that I did a
contest and I won that contest so I went
from the Long Beach to the Ice House
annex room
remember Barbara that owns a flappers
now she had this little three show on
Friday and Saturday like you it would be
a 7 o'clock 9 o'clock smaller in a small
annex yeah so I started doing those that
all the time and then I got into the
haha at a you know haha and then that
terian I did that then from there I got
a you know I tried to get showcases at
the Comedy Store so I was doing the
hangout thing until I got my showcase
finally she didn't even talk to me Mitsy
didn't even look at me man didn't even
look at me I was she was standing
sitting in her booth looking and I was
standing there trying to get Jay Davis
goes up before me mm-hmm
he gets passed I wanted to kill myself a
Mitzi Mitzi is she I feel like I the
only reason that I got past the Comedy
Store was because I met him ed sat next
to her and said you have to throw a lot
of people man got me my boy am ed got me
the other thing too since then we're no
longer acquaintances anymore but you
know that's a whole other story but he's
one of got that initial showcase and it
was until a year and a half later of
like badgering Tommy and dealing with
Tommy and so then you kept you just kept
going back kept going back I was doing
whatever spots I could and Tommy finally
gave me another showcase it was in the
main room at that time too they were
doing them sometimes on those Vargas
Mason bringer shows they would do like
showcases and she would be sitting in
the booth and I did it then you
I remember to doing that set I ran the
light I was like nah you gonna see me oh
you gonna see me do my you know I mean
I'll give a [ __ ] you know you know and
then I'm walking in the hallway and
they're what they're helping her because
she was sick at that time so they were
helping her go through the the hallway
to the kitchen and she stopped and she
looked at me and she said you were funny
boom there was only word she ever spoke
to wow I need to hear that's all I
needed to hear it then after that then
Tommy gave with a bow you know you're
gonna be in the belly room for like a
year you know good old Tommy you know I
never met Tommy Tommy she appreciated
Tommy was an amazing there was a method
to the masa way
no Tommy got moved on Tommy got fired
yeah but Tommy Tommy was a I really
liked Tommy he was such a calming
Samaritan man he was the guy at the
comics we ran it he was that he was the
gatekeeper yeah and Tommy would he had
such reverence for comics permit see yes
for the store and he loved comedy and he
came to be an actor and he was kind of a
good-looking kid when he was a baby
guitar yeah and I remember I said to
Tommy he was he was I recorded a
conversation with him one time and I
lost it was so fast man you recorded I
told him I said yeah because I said I
you're gonna I want to play I want a
murderer I want to write a character
like you so I recorded him talking and
he was I can't describe the way but he
was a guy who would say use your name
he'd go and I'll tell you something
Brennan at the end of the day and
Brendan real a friend in comedy I've
always said this Brendan comedy is you
know and he had these philosophies on
comedy but they needed say something
completely off the wall I was like I go
because you know I need to lead guitar
playing guitar and could sing no he was
Deloitte and playing guitar and singing
I go you can sing and play guitar go you
I didn't know you were a nice because
Brian it came here to be an actor and a
singer and he would say he would also
say said what happened I'm talented than
more talented than everybody that comes
into this club well he and I said what
happens was just yeah I said what
happened he goes you know what I
couldn't deal with all the guys trying
to [ __ ] me there are a lot of homos
swear to god he was a little prejudiced
a little bit of a bigot he was saying
that he was saying he was I think what
he's saying is a charming you know
attractive is a young man that he got so
much male attention like he was dead he
wasn't being that's why it wasn't
successful that's what that was what I
mean he was it works didn't really gel
there so that so then you know we got I
guess I don't hate him he thinks I do
you read the concert so anyway I have to
be at the Comedy Store then I went over
to the Laugh Factory and then but at
that same time other things were
happening in my career like what well I
I think yeah I got it I got a commercial
agent I I finally got a manager I got I
went to new faces and then I got a real
agent that got me on the road and then I
in 2010 I booked workaholics and but was
acting always kind of the goal yeah yeah
I wouldn't you know why got it's a
comedy I wanted to be the sitcom dad you
know I mean I wanted to be on Reba my
favorite credit of is but yeah but was a
great show is what I'm saying that was a
workaholic 16 how workaholics is a great
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but that's your age
range you know you've never seen
Millennials but that's good me for you
yeah no not for you yeah you were like
61 when workaholics like people my age
people my age especially like like my
brothers like people who work 9:00 to
5:00 it's like yeah that's [ __ ] yeah you
know that's our sign field well when
Eric and I it is yeah Eric and I had a
good well you're my you're closer to my
yeah and we do and I had such a good
conversation at Montreal where
emerges talking you about life and I
thought to myself it was it was it was
nice to sit back and just sit with a
dude who's who's lived as long as I have
almost and you know we had a very we had
a very tame old middle-aged conversation
right let me tell you something you know
what's happening to me right now and I'm
talking about this on stage cuz how old
are you 34 so far you're you're you're
getting passion Millennial age you're
millennial stage but what I'm realizing
is being in the entertainment business
and being on workaholics and you know I
had this I think I had this delusion
that I was cool and hip I had this
delusion that like young people
connected with me you know and what I
realized is I have more in common with
people over 45
than I do with kids under 35 that's
right and so now I'm talking about this
on stage and I'm realizing like Oh imma
old do ya you know I'm actually an old
guy I'm actually like you know I'm
wearing like comfortable Church nurse
shoes on today because I'm like yeah you
know but you know but a kid might be
like old shoes day and I'm realizing I'm
going I'm waking up and going like oh I
just realized I'm old yeah you know and
so I gotta take care of things and like
you know so that's why when I do sit
down with people and I go oh cuz it's
like by the way this is a compliment to
you all right you are literally the only
comedian that I don't mind is on all the
time okay all the time Late Late but I'm
talking about on off literally the only
one that I just go Bob Ryan he's so
funny
you know cuz everyone else I'm like you
wanna kiss did this one [ __ ] okay
does he have to joke all the time do you
always have to be joking you're
literally just like you're in the pocket
of where it's like ah sky love this guy
that's literally what is this guy it's
got you mean goes just dude I know
you're working with a dietician anything
else with psoriasis just this what I
have to say he goes the tribe meditation
and calming down its stress is causing
here he was a great I've cameras name
for the email me but it was you know I
was like you know what you're right he
goes try better taste my mother said the
same thing but no I won't I'm gonna burn
celadon
I'm gonna [ __ ] burn well I have
energy and I have a lot of energy boy
energy than me now that I changed my
diets even worst I'm not drinking now
I'm reading you're so bald oh sorry well
take read see we're gonna send you
drinks just a light therapy I'm gonna be
good hey I started like you know it's
like it's funny that all the podcast
world is like there's this like you know
incest you'll you know cuz like between
Rogan Ari Shaffir and like you guys
opening the podcast calling me fat you
know Bailey
this guy he did do it as well and then I
was watching another episode of Rogan
and we're like cuz I said this thing on
Rogan where I said like what's the
practical use of jujitsu I just asked
the question because we were talking
about it and then that turn over
yeah that tried to do a whole thing
we're pretty good crash people are
sending me videos like so he was had
somebody else on and the guy was like
yeah I heard that guy and then Rogan
said well that's just my friend Eric
Griffin making excuses to not work out
so I heard that and I was like this
[ __ ] motivation motivation
because like I told the story before but
like Ari Shaffir one time I just got
back from the Middle East doing tours
with a med you know and you eat like a I
was a fat [ __ ] when I came back like I
didn't even realize it I'm in the
hallway with already just talking in the
middle of the conversation he reaches up
and squeezes my cheek like this
conversation flows up to my cheek and
goes like this and then ask the question
hey what's going on literally listen to
me
the next day I signed up at LA at
Bally's with a are you good next day the
next day I got a trainer and then I
passed out I almost passed out while I
was working out with this trainer he had
to rush down and get a protein bar oh
yeah my blood sugar was low because I
was up on this thing like it's
[ __ ] Ari dude you going ham on
the waves kill a man yeah tarik I seen
target got a gym there's all these gyms
and in power MMA guy great shape and
everything else but you know he's big
he's barrel-chested big afghani guy and
his tummy his tummy we were talking and
I and he had a t-shirt on and his tummy
was relaxed and so and he's bein he's a
good-good like we all are
and I go and all I did we're in we're in
his driveway and I go like this I go ah
man oh I just look this time I go anyway
that's all right there man oh and I
touched you touch this time ooh that's
all I did
yeah she said three week
don't worry about that part well that
sent him off he told me month I see him
like three months later he goes red now
cuz when you said that show even a guy
like me I don't even I'm not an athletic
guy I was in high school you know I was
like you know I was all League and I
just got played basketball I had a
skinny body I was like you know I was
like yeah you know I could dunk you know
I mean I was I was gladly but and you
just get older and you're just like it's
like no is that something that was like
a thing for me there's so much fun do I
look but now I'm working out I feel like
people and maybe it's my own issues but
I feel like people assume comedians are
gonna look like that we should look
mommy's not supposed to look like this
yeah you know I already said that you
went on and we were doing sets at The
Improv you said that you went out Brian
went then I went or vice versa then you
gotta have to it I don't what the [ __ ]
that is I was like that would be like
what you just started Manson you were
pretty horrible terrible and I take
offense sometimes to like these
outsiders coming in these hobbyists yeah
you go and I go well this would be like
me going I want to go UFC fight tomorrow
yesterday Washington last night for the
first time in a long time and I forgot
that he's been doing so much standing I
thought so and I can't watch him because
I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna I give him 15
notes and I'm exhausting so he avoids me
because I don't blame him cuz he's like
let me find my way Brian so meanwhile
the [ __ ] I haven't come on Rob
cinnamon like I went I was watching him
last night at the Comedy Store in a room
full of strangers [ __ ] kill him and I
went this all new material I want this
[ __ ] means economic man we take
the difference between the difference
between our era and what's happening now
is so he you took your success and fame
level from what you did before and then
you transition into doing comedy that
transition is your open mic yeah okay
that's your open mic huh
so a person that has a lot of followers
on Instagram that wants to now be a
comic that's their open mic nobody wants
to do open mics now but that's all we
had yeah all we had a job that was the
only option
he also took his work am I
so he just took it I don't have a
problem saying what I'm saying is I
don't have it let me just finish this I
don't have an issue now when I see like
even if it's like you know it's some hot
chick on Instagram and she's got a
million followers but she wants to be a
comic and then you have these like you
know pseudo female comics out here like
well she's doing it because I go none
enough she's just better at Instagram
than you correct that's all that it is
and then now she's out here trying to do
it
that's that process now and we're in
this kind of like wild wild west of like
comedy but this is not anything new it's
like when an actor for my show decide
yes I want to be a comic now like Jeremy
pivens Jeremy pivens is out here doing
it now he's headlining all over the
country but yeah Jeremy pivens don't
have to go to a coffee shop in Reseda
because he's Jeremy's on stage since he
was so his weight is also very
black-and-white dope because like like
CM Punk let's say I stroll on the CM
Punk of comedy right so CM Punk came
from WWE went to UFC it was very
apparent within the first three minutes
this [ __ ] cannot fight he's not
gonna have a career doing this in comedy
it's pretty apparent to either you're
getting laughs so you're not harvest but
also there's some people who won't say
names come in they have a the fanbase
and they're only playing towards their
crap that's that's your the funny uncle
at the barbecue yeah but they're not
doing sets but what are you supposed to
do I mean here's the process though see
you've jumped the step see the step that
we had to take to go to the shittiest
shows in the country to go to the
shittiest shows in LA to go to open mics
that was our learning curve and the
process of building up that chop if
you're just coming in and people are
coming to you because they know you from
such-and-such you your tendency is going
to be the like let me play to my crowd
because that's why they're here but you
playing for home crowds but my open mics
were with Brian I had he even a bigger
advantage because I had a bicycle with
training wheels on cuz I was allowed to
do live find the kids and Brian would go
do use go tell story for ten minutes
first grabbed on you don't tell us story
so that was my that it happened yeah
and Brian would come onstage and then we
would riff for an hour back and forth
I'd find my you know whatever my my my
voice and stuff like that we did that
for two years before I was like you know
I'm gonna start trying stamp I remember
he came to me into I just got up and
even me I was like and I've been his
biggest believer but I was like stand up
yeah oh yeah oh my voice got real hot Oh
after that I remember I told I told
because my brother's big fan of yours
and I go damn my boy here kind of clown
mom me at that it goes really and then
you're on Rogen and then I think I told
rollin around this dude that's just how
to tell that we bust chops man it's like
you're in the locks come that's all sure
Russell Peters did the same thing to me
like that but if Russell does that means
he likes you if they don't say anything
your [ __ ] yeah so then people thought we
didn't like each other yeah yeah and
then I did you I hate you what because I
was like yo dude this is like a thing
that's out there because I first of all
I don't know how big Rogan was the
podcast I didn't know how big it was
until I just did it and then I got that
weekend the first time I ever got like
sellouts at Irvine improv yeah you know
what I mean and it's a combination of
things my special just came out American
warrior on Showtime my special came out
and then I'm dying appears and then then
the Rogaine now I feel like people who
come to see me I just went to Phoenix
and I had like yeah just a great crowds
and I'm like whoa it's starting to
happen deserve all of the podcast but
yeah no no I'm saying it's it's an
accumulation it's telling point but that
but the people that listen to podcasts
are people that are like oh I want to go
out and watch comedy you know because
they're taking they're going out of
their way to be like I want to listen to
this on my own time three hours for
three hours so these are the kind of
people that like oh I'm gonna go I want
to go do this so you know it's just it's
just you when you when you heard him say
he want to be a stand-up I feel like
that as an older guy now - when I hear
somebody be like I wanna be a stand-up I
don't want to even deal with this person
because I'm like you need to do this for
like three or four years before I would
even want to talk to you because I know
how crazy this business
yes but I realized though good for you
for being like now taking him under your
wing we don't do that enough well yeah
yeah and I don't know if I even I hope
you'll say this about to me but I always
think people like Brendan like you know
because the way you took him under your
wing I don't like that only for this
reason the dude would have found his way
dudes like this they're gonna find their
way I happen to I'll give you myself
this much credit you know what I saw I
saw I saw huge potential like I saw this
dude and I was like I'm like that's
telling me stories and making me laugh
he's a [ __ ] athlete but why is he so
fun that's what coaching yeah and and he
was interested in it and he was like
kind of weirdly artistic he'd wrestled
and I was like there's something
different about this dude so but if
anything and then we do a podcast and it
becomes really popular and then we all
get on the road and all I did was I go I
think you could do this and I you know
you can go out and tell some stories
that's all it was so it wasn't this
existence I think that he would people
like this and it just success wise in
life people like him don't they find
their way my boy was real I hate each
other know like Whitney would you damn
ear like dude some guys Chicago said you
upset like no not at all man I didn't I
didn't know I thought Russell Peters
hate me first thing I thought you aide
me and with you at it sites cuz they
getting me my brother such big fans of
the show I'm like dude Eric hey man
brothers like [ __ ] that show I just saw
him so I'm like foil dawg yeah oh you
think I haven't watched it since it's
old but watch it back now even though
it's over karma hey Jay come to Chicago
god dammit
yeah but my ex Rogan he's like you guys
don't hate each other no you think know
what I'm saying those like give yourself
a little bit of credit cuz it's like
when you're our mentor a coach yeah yeah
sure you're not just coaching anybody
sure you know like this no it's not a
comic hang out in a sense a magic like
you I'm gonna make everybody a comic no
you tell you
last night he got off he had a great set
you killed her I was so impressed I love
that I got on I thought my thing
bribed me goes [ __ ] around
I [ __ ] destroy ground like all right
now my friends I grab my hand oh don't
ever [ __ ] forget that I'm the king
and a sensei check it out when he tells
you when he starts going maybe you
should do your own shows that's when you
know you're really doing good you don't
have some but yeah you know you get to a
point where you just like that's but
that you could show your progress and
it's just like fighting what I notice I
would boxing I'm in the analogy of this
is that when I first started doing it I
didn't know he was like one you know and
I'm like okay well now they don't have
to say anything that you could comedy in
it is the same way it's right you know
you stay put in the work you can start
to feel like oh I got it all right I
could do this yeah I think you start to
really get funny and that's one like
you're pure you becomes a peer yeah then
he's starting to look at you like oh hey
you go first I mean that that's the
first time you looked at men and went oh
this guy's funny
I swear to God like I know exactly you
know that's my last I don't mat right
Matt good-looking kid my younger brother
with the straight you wish well ya know
I had some kid handsome hands I mean
like like if you adopted him from a
good-looking well he says if you want a
physique trade
yeah we're in the same outfit last night
is what I'm saying I go man looks like
he could be your son yeah oh my but way
better looking
yeah Matt's a cute kid but Matt is like
I have no messes he was like 14 and like
I've been like trying to tell him Talent
dude you got it so he was in Irvine with
me and now that's the first time I was
watching him and I said oh [ __ ] yeah man
I was like you you're he turned into a
comic Matt's legit he tried to a comic
Matt I didn't even realize know at 22
years old that kid is legit he did calm
he turned it and he's like he's still
comfortable now yes he did on a stool
and he's just like relax yeah like he's
comfortable his own skin he likes Justin
Bieber of Hollywood looks like the
acting is gonna be like someone some big
Ang's Mike no I said you're the next
Channing Tatum if you play your cards
right he found his way and he's working
on a nice house in Atlanta with me you
know but it's gonna get to a point one
on but I'm gonna be like it's already
like already hits I got his social media
presence is already dwarfing mine you
know what I mean and it's because that's
his crowd I'm looking at I'm like he
doesn't even know yeah he's on the road
to likes real thing Korea you know and
it's like you know and I just like being
here and I'm just like oh I love seeing
but I had that moment with him in Irvine
you know I was looking at him onstage
and I was like oh he legitimately made
me laugh I know and I had to tell him
and I said to him I said dude this is
the first time like I like I really was
like I wasn't gonna know it's the first
time that I wasn't he's a good-looking
kid look at him I know look at this
bastard come on he's a straight man
straight man he's the first time I
looked at him and I wasn't trying to
coach him right guys are a church
fathers yeah others yeah we're just like
hey God I think you should like so
that's the protective father and I get
this guy every time I just go on stage
and I go this is what comedy is supposed
to look like guys dude he's paint yeah
good look he get to the rim too we've
spotted glove works he's some reason why
I went to glove work okay yeah I mean so
he's like he texts me he's like are you
gonna be in the gym move around
he said he messed up his hand on your
head that's not true maybe but he's
young huh he's 22 yeah it's only 22
little bastards know that well forget he
needs to be in movies now next while I
do that he's trying he's doing it though
when you
look that good and you're funny which he
is and he's getting funnier and funnier
watch what he's the problem here's a
problem when you start young young when
you start 14 15 16 you get away with
murder you're born you get away with not
being talented yeah you get away with
like people going ah you know but now
he's a man yeah so now he's 22 so now
all 22 I don't look at I was like it but
but even at 22 nobody's giving you any
excuses now no so now you have to be
funny you got to be talented you have to
live up but he's taken them she tries
taking himself seriously yeah he's
working out he looks great he everything
he's doing is that right he's hungry
he's not more steel as teeth I just had
to tell him when you look he's a monster
you should but he got him to like you
know he got on to a little thing it's
public knowledge now you know you we
don't have to talk about just Google it
Google Matt ryf relationship we will say
but you know I I wanted to say to her
the girls got it you know she's got a
daughter mmm well things just a man let
me get your daughter's number you know I
wanted it because I was like no no yeah
but I found myself being Papa Bear just
like yeah yeah yeah you know you do
makes the three of us look like [ __ ]
toads yeah yeah that's right
we look like toads next that's right I
know a gentleman who happens to be a
little bit gay whether he knows it or
not
and oh Matt was talking the gentleman
looked at me and some other people in he
goes where's that guy that we were
talking about and I pointed directly and
he drifted on over man he drifted right
onto him
yeah
you were there Matt's equipped to deal
with that type of attention he knows how
to do could this like yeah I'm a
straight man and I give him that kind of
attention he knows how to do look at the
mouth on the kid good I'll take good
hard money if you can hold on you decide
no lady boy he's a beautiful nose juicy
ass lips mmm glad you can see on the
screen there we won't talk that's the
girl that's her she you know she's our
age know that famous actors click on
that yeah Kate Beckinsale well done
brother well done dude how's that a
party she walked in and I lost all
energy of my body she is mushy I mean
when I met her she knew who I was and
she was like I know you don't hurt him
you know she's all British are they
still uh I don't know I don't talk about
it god bless him you know he's you know
he's very sensitive man yeah you know so
he's like that's why he she should know
better no no she created in a lab yeah
yeah and funny and again once again
funny yes you so much I remember I'm
really like I'm annoyed by it
you know be like if Brad if I could Brad
Pitt went into comedy I'd be like dude
come on man
and then just crush that enough he's up
there maybe a Brad Pitt was onstage
crushing yeah yeah yeah I would want to
kill him but then really friendly to his
job is to dry hump like Jennifer Aniston
and Jai Angelina Jolie in movies he gets
to dry hump them for 20 million dollars
and then he gets to come home to a
beautiful last wife and kids and then
also he's funny
now you don't get to do all that I'm not
having it the hell is look at just every
picture of him with this that's when I
knew him see the one that says beef yeah
I click that one like that's home Wow
it's you'd see the teeth of a kid Oh yet
his struggle City there he fixed his
teeth he was like he spent healing but
he didn't have car insurance but he had
money to get that so he said to us
you have no idea how much these teeth
cost me huh yeah yeah he's all about it
whatever [ __ ] teeth might be too much
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] my teeth like a
vampire vampire dog that's a garage
[Laughter]
first ones about you cuz it just emits
key
I was watching Rogan podcast assured he
had stopped in Iran okay and then they
pulled up Wikipedia is that boxer again
mixed martial art anime slider up ten in
the world now about just beat who's that
that box are drawn ball back so they're
on he was on Rogen's podcast and they
capilla and you're Brendan called Jeff
Novitzky the Golden Snitch a while ago
and it's caught up so much that it's on
Wikipedia now you can actually see his
name right here Jeffrey John David
the golden smashed great yes it's crazy
and style bender oh he was just talking
about the golden snake is referring to
me you don't snitch you say good words
about you too why does the gal bender
did my knees snitch on somebody like
well I don't get the reference so he's
in charge cycle McGee's ultimate snitch
the Golden Snitch
this is forever ago yeah and it's karma
it's a nightmare
yeah I do feel like some people are
getting away with it can I ask a
question I'm gonna ask there is a
certain fighter in the last year see and
if that's if that's natural
Bob you don't map all across the
craziest [ __ ] I've ever seen but what
about Francis and Donna and they're both
tested they're both tested but have you
seen this is he jacked you should pull
the picture Cup Kobe Kobe looks like a
month away you see Mike Bibby yeah oh
yeah that's gotta be some dudes what I'm
saying is like there's there's a natural
workout that you can get yourself
looking pump were jacked and then
there's like you know taking certain
supplements that don't make it like
exact Kobe on top left currently got
like that when he's eating in that
training somehow like this no that's
when he got out of shape and he put no
no he got in shape
yeah yes I saw it was on TMZ or
something he was outside a hotel room a
hotel and he's just holding his daughter
and he just looked like he was so jacked
oh there goes Brian looking super Jack
Kobe Bryant you might come back into the
league I don't want some come back and
play with LeBron yeah but I'm just
letting a bomb what a frickin nature
that guy is some people don't realize
I'm in that man is a complete point if I
see I I would I don't know I would
assume those guys are on some sort of PD
why wouldn't you be if you're LeBron
you're allowed to use it for recovery I
said just on Rogen's thing I was like
you know I think that athletes should be
allowed to have an off season
use because that's what the doctor gives
regular people yeah yeah if I break my
ankle the doctor puts you on a steroid
you can get healed let him do that yeah
I give them like here's your two months
especially in basketball well yeah
they're also basketball really doesn't
test they there's not that strict they
test like once a year so you saw that we
know is super strict and testing all
kinds of stuff right bring up a cost
again I hate doing it you solids not but
you saw this not really Haley remember
you saw us not the end-all be-all I know
there's never one corruption and you saw
it as well what do you mean by that well
this is you know I mean your amp this
guy's really young think 25 look look at
when your to look at the body no no but
this is this is a six-month saying maybe
he's just six months like here he is in
September then here he is maybe he's a
genetic it's possible but that's crazy
muscularity I guess it's dude what else
I'll do though one this that that's your
life then open a lot of guys who trains
25 Brenda Brenda Brenda with no gun to
your head what are you saying I mean
he's gonna be the nuisance been in the
game for so long I mean I would say it's
very suspect I mean come on Wow oh isn't
it crazy to be at your optimal do you
have to be doing something else like is
this how we're supposed to look no well
yeah and he's real absolutely and
everything else I'm just saying that if
that is genetics that mean we should we
should put him in a museum in the
bathroom and get his DNA
he's obviously naturally very muscular
but that's that's when you see him like
a compared to Vitor Belfort they say
always I don't get to be the he's
fighting am a fan of habit I don't try
to be a dick out of your face bro yeah
I'm a fan I don't want to take any way
from his victory I just it's just
ridiculous that is very strict can I ask
you like who I personally as an outside
person that doesn't really like this
sport I think is too violent
you know I'll always think of Muhammad
Ali and how he died and how sure that's
that's what I think about so I think you
a sports fan though yeah I'm a huge
sports fan but I just don't find I find
this to be like so violent and not
appealing to me but at the same time as
an outsider I go I don't care if he
takes steroids who cares
mm-hmm like this whole idea this myth
that because first of all working out
six days a week so if you're working out
six days a week and another guy is
working out four days a week then you
already have an advantage so it should
be like if you're gonna really do it it
should be like we have to do the same
exact workout for six months the exact
same thing use the same exact diet our
damage and then fight but the only
problem with fight you know in all other
sports besides football fighting I do
not care if you're on steroids I don't
give a [ __ ] matter of fact I approve of
them the only reason why Fighting's a
little different because let's say you
and I are gonna fight in 12 weeks and I
take a boatload of stage you could kill
somebody it's gonna help me drive this
fist through your face
I get faster and stronger well I think
in other sports I think it should matter
if it's gonna make if it's gonna if it's
gonna ask about I didn't [ __ ] yeah but
if it's gonna make somebody jomeyer yeah
baseball
I want more home I mean it saved
baseball yeah you know it did you guys
see uh Sammy Sammy Sosa first of all you
look like Michael Jackson
you're like worse than worse though yeah
he was so white it was crazy
and then he literally had the nerve to
put his mouth to say like I I never was
tested you know I did I've never failed
a test did you do the steroids or not is
now an attack here yeah it's like we
care oh my look at him he looks like a
Wow well there's I'll see you know
Spence well they probably put extra on
that picture they go on social media the
lights all [ __ ] up makeup that I have
psoriasis hey baby I'm gonna be a red
man red man lobster I was like Eddie
Munster from our view looks crazy
how about that thing you're wearing your
skin change you guys yeah I use a lotion
I don't know what it's just this what
happens when I use this lotion is it
believe there's a lotion you buy these
days that turns your skin
he was Bobby I don't think you can go
black
for apples and bleep like Eric if I want
to turn black is there a black lotion no
idea dude look at me I'm a mixed man I'm
a mixed bag white black dad you know no
my mom my mom actually looks more like
me it's more fair-skinned you know are
you Jewish and flat just this all I get
I get all kinds of different things you
know I'm just so racially ambiguous my
mom my fluid my family's from a lot of
family from Belize yeah my dad was like
like European or something I never met
him so what does she get you all right
so this was in the news something called
plane Bay have you guys heard a plane
bay no okay so there's a woman playing
Bay plain Bay like Bay like a
boyfriend/girlfriend me okay plane is an
airplane so this is your plane Bay oh is
it
this woman right here she was live I
guess she was tweeting about something
that happened on the plane where she
gave up her seat because she wanted to
sit next to her boyfriend who had the
seat behind her mm-hmm so she gave it up
and then she was sitting next a really
pretty girl she was hoping that some
like strange nice handsome stranger
would come sit next to her that happened
and they seemed to hit it off so she was
tweeting about it uh-huh and then it got
like 300 thousand retweets because it
was like this romantic thing Wow love
story love story yeah and then there's a
podcast and she's going on the road with
two kids what happened so the guy was
super good-looking the girls you know
really pretty and then they had all
these things in common and they were
actually starting to get you know this
romantic thing going on and she even
said oh they're going to the bathroom
together
oh she sucked them off on the plane
today but you start how do you write
what happened after it so I've just a
lot of people were like this is so
romantic and everything I think
celebrities even liked it and everything
that's why I got somebody reach yeah it
wasn't about that it was about it just
takes one yeah and then that and that
person that dries out too what sets it
off exactly so what happened June so
after that
then people started turning on her
saying it's an invasion of privacy
because he did that girl it's America
yeah but the girl that was part of the
thing she didn't want to be a part of it
so she even told the lady like don't you
know don't say anything huh I don't know
you never know but then think about if
someone's doing that to you does
everything have to be on social media
doesn't say no it's just kind of like it
is an invasion of privacy and now
there's I don't think she's doing any
ill-will like I took it I took a page
out of their part in this dude was
passed out I had these short cut off
shorts jean shorts is like balls were
barely hanging out the front and these
big gut and he's just has his American
hat flag on our side cuff I was if I
appreciate someone with good wet the way
they dress in the airport salgo Airport
swaggy of the day issues of the day and
I liked him I was like here port swag of
the day not met the jean shorts and then
after I post I thought [ __ ] man what if
he sees well you're very famous now it
does change it I know I'm not making fun
of this you are sheep no I like this
[ __ ]
own your [ __ ] own it you were you were
looking down on him you saw that big gut
and here how dare you were short on eye
where you had the same history now way
shorter bro but this one way shorter
warm I was jealous because I was hot
know this yeah but I'm trying to be a
politician right now you're doing saying
you're doing Sammy Sosa right now yo
Sammy Sosa just only ever has God so did
they get in trouble though no although
the guy actually he went on and and I
guess Instagram or Twitter and then
revealed himself he said leave the girl
alone
oh I gave her privacy alone yeah I agree
yeah that's the guy he's them here I'm
sure also to say thank you to everyone
for respecting Helen's privacy at this
moment they say her name so I was still
out to take on board in such a short
period of time and it can be pretty
overwhelming but she's being super
supportive and
thank you guys he's already got a knee
he doing for the grant always doing it
for the gram you look just like that
[ __ ] you guys ever save have you
picked that I picked up but I've done
work on planes you've done work on
planes yeah I say where's the ladies
yeah when they sit down next to close
I'll tell you why that's the best time
cuz yeah because it is all about who you
are it is all about this in a relative
status it's all about yeah well you're
obviously you're gonna be enough you
know I did it all from coach that's a
good [ __ ] title I did it all from
Coates
no but I think you know like I find
myself being very charming
you know yet to know me how much
charming guy I used to get lucky she's
hot yet is she she's hot on the gram
together don't look if you don't mind I
want to get through in 2000 there's
Brian counter there am yes I was looking
at by real quick oh there you go with
them all the time no I go down there's a
picture of us someplace way down just
keep going a lot of work the holic stuff
oh no I'm dying up here
tell me more are you sad I'm dying up
here is ending well I don't know if it's
ending or not we don't know you really
yeah but you know if I had to there but
there we are oh wow you know I mean
pretty yeah that's cold
how long you guys been together yeah
that's gonna be a year we've known each
other a year but being officially
together in August I believe it'll be a
year you guys live together no no I mean
she's like she's younger than me and I
just want to be like make sure you [ __ ]
together she I think she way younger no
they're not way younger you know I
already got in trouble saying her age on
the last podcast I was young man si se I
really don't
her whole thing is like I well look you
know I want people to think I'm Way too
young girl I said now you make me look
creepy yeah that's cool yeah so bad my I
just come from an era of like I don't
believe in like living with somebody
until you know that this is like would
now regard we're in for the long haul
from the six it's pretending to be
married I told you she's very pretty
girl but anyway what I'm saying I was
like it's funny she says this to me all
the time she said she's she said this to
me yet other days hilarious because
she's like you know if I just walked by
you I wouldn't be like oh I got to get
me some of that our inter personality so
she said she goes you know I got we
started you started talking we started
talking and stuff and I was like oh wow
you know so I get that like some guys
have you meet her at some guys had that
we actually met on Instagram she uh you
slid in her D no no it's like well let
me say the first story is she was a fan
of I'm dying up here she's never even
seen workaholics which is great for me
because of workaholics people are crazy
but um you know but they actually I've
had some experiences but that's a whole
other story she she what I saw was you
know how you see people that like your
pictures so I saw three likes and a
follow from her oh that's like your girl
girl I guess I slid into the damn right
away I was like yo what's up did I get
off that [ __ ] right away I said come to
my show yeah I say you should come to my
show so she came to my show with a date
though you know I loved it I thought it
was like how honest you know yeah cuz
she even asked me say well I need to get
tickets and I think gonna bring somebody
to cut you to get drinks and I was like
that's fine so I'm doing my set and I
have a whole set about like we're not
gonna be friends set so I was doing that
material I'm letting her know we hang on
the friend yeah I'm all set on friends
yeah yeah
I'm good I'm good I said I have Jordans
that are older than you so we're not
gonna be not we're not gonna be friends
say Wow all right so then we buy a week
or so later I met her at of Jazz Club
you know that we just that's that's what
we started doing you know we just
started going to dinners and hanging out
she came to shows and I was like oh he's
just uh she's the coolest chick you ever
want to meet and you know I love her I
really did I was wondering why women
like I'll always look good I don't I
think women are so cerebral I said to my
wife she's straight up setting a goal
we're talking and I said guys
good-looking guy she goes man I go what
do you mean he's a stud I always wonder
why I go why you date why you found me
attractive versus someone like that and
she goes she's lying dude yeah she goes
because you're filthy and charismatic
yeah and I went oh I'm filthy he said to
me she said to me she said to me one
time we're just laying in there she's
like you know if I was 22 I would not be
in your bed right and try and I said to
her if you were 22 I would have kicked
you out already you know saw me so we
just I just in do you women get to a
certain age where they just know what's
important to find her find in like she
finds good-looking guys attractive all
the time we're watching TV TV or
something she's like whoohoo and I'm
like I get it percent stupid knowledge
that he's stupid just yeah the elephants
in the room of course that dudes [ __ ]
good-looking dude or the girls hot of
course so it's like you you get that
kind of like that's I always love going
up on stage after Chris D'Elia you know
I love gonna I love cuz I love teasing
the crowds I go like there's my
boyfriend's gone yes I guess it's funny
how these girls are let go the girls
laugh at Chris differently they laugh at
me of course you know that's fine you
know he's like the most he's like nah
[ __ ] Chrissy charismatic you know and
handsome and rugged he's got all these
things going on talked Andy he's all
like you would have hated our
conversation I got Dhulia the new the
new Yeezys the dad Yeezys and here's bro
can you drop me off on it I'm sure it's
[ __ ] not getting your shoes and then
drop them off in the Holly
yeah I went via skype bro got an idea
and I ordered an uber and the guy comes
pick me up I go you're just gonna drop
these shoes up at my friend's house then
sent the yoruba then Chris takes picture
with the with the uber driving their
kicks like boom you hated the combat
he's like these guys are long in depth
conversations about shoes I've been
shooting can we go to dinner with Chris
like you say hey I'll meet you at
whatever yes you get there this
[ __ ] is already ordered and he's
halfway through his food yeah
please eat the biggest diva a creature
of habit yeah yeah yeah over the same
thing over and over this is a good news
story okay all the Thai kids and
everyone everyone involved that's better
everyone involved in this hi rescue is
now the only person that coming on the
road with me yeah so they were white
kids this story would have been just
like through the roof you think I don't
think you'd been the story it's pretty
worldwide no no it would have been a
story I feel like the way bigger story
my sweet a dead there was Asian scuba
diving in there just to get the rights
to this coming near like this movie's
gonna get me tomorrow this is what we do
this is how we understand I'm not gonna
listen I'm not gonna understand this
unless it happens to my kids yeah
how about the how about throwing person
that died was a Navy SEAL a Thai Navy
SEALs the only person that died yeah
what just but he did give them the
oxygen tank so he died doing something
you know courageous and for sure another
thing that sucks about this though is
there's an Australian doctor that flew
there who is it was actually a badass he
has 30 years experience diving right
he's the one that stayed with the kids
till the very end and then he was the
last one to leave the cave when he got
out he found out that his father like
moments later passed away and so it's
such a like a bittersweet ending for
this guy but you know what stabs
probably pop a beer was on death's
doorstep though you know probably by the
way he did his job save the kids
what else you get yeah where we gonna go
from there thanks
I don't look at Debbie Downer over
trying to bring this is the good news no
no but the kids are free everyone
everyone's safe now but this is another
weird one so this lady she's her name's
Pru Goward she's a minister for
prevention of domestic violence and
sexual assault for a new south wales
australia she's trying to pass a law
that says that says you have to say yes
you have to ask for sex and they have to
say yes scroll on to X let me see them
of course otherwise it could be deemed
rape no I can't read signs it will have
to be very much like shut the [ __ ] yeah
you're telling me and now you're getting
in the bedroom and saying I have to
speak no awesome this is Sharon notary B
you don't have a contract this left-wing
insanity this far left-wing insanity but
of course that makes sense to her yeah
look at her you don't get laid you're
[ __ ] for real she's like this is for
real these are the people who are think
about what she's saying
just wild l-dub get into the bedroom and
I have to speak now you tell the state
the state will accuse me of rape Brian
you're gonna have to take the gag out of
the chicks mouth well let me step in for
a second here what we're trying to
legislate now is behavior of like how
we're supposed to treat each other like
people were like that we're trying to
legislate a world where should you have
one-night stands should you should you
invite a chick over to your apartment
that you barely know like this is just
about like maybe we should be treating
each other nicer maybe we should be a
gentleman maybe men should be gentlemen
but it's like where our thought process
is hey I met you at the bar and I
invited you over I don't even know you
if you don't know that we're trying to
[ __ ] right now what's going on no
personal responsibility I'm personal
responsibility all swarthy obvious to
both sides are guilt but the problem is
this there is um there is it's okay to
have a moment of being like yo I don't
want to do this I mean the problem is I
create this is gonna create paranoia
on a scale where your think about this
well do just go [ __ ] it and also also
you might get accused of rape your life
is over I know man yeah just point now
like with an accusation yes bring it cuz
dude might you have [ __ ] this way over
here I don't have to deal with it well
yeah that that's what uh James Hardin
did have yer jinx aren't did he had this
side piece this girl she's a former
stripper the greatest Blau ass you've
ever seen and he goes I strictly I pay
her monthly fee
I fly underwear it's just sex she can't
press signed a contract and there's no
charges there's nothing I do that song
to [ __ ] with these and that and that's
what happens and you know loses women on
that yeah they the women women lose on
romance on all that stuff some men men
men will figure out a way to adapt as
usual especially with the robots come
that's a dum-dum right there see her
because of the few situations where this
has been officially I think it all
exception yeah the exceptions have now
become the rule and it's like we're
covering ourselves that this rule is the
same reason why we got to take our shoes
off when we go to the airport mmm that's
right no you know a lot of us also I
have to say though I have to I have to
say is that I've kisses when you have a
man who brags about grabbing women by
their [ __ ] right and a man who brags
about essentially assaulting a woman
right and then when I heard that as a
man
I went I'm a bro but I went oh you're
done bro you're done you just got you
just sigh no and he didn't get
disqualified oh and then he became
presence of so and so so women go and a
lot of people touch him they could they
get terrified yeah maybe they went wait
a minute this is terrified he's also
untouchable statement alright that's the
culture [ __ ] and then so you can
understand that that reality for a lot
of me to advocates was like look we're
in a war here if this guy's gonna get
elected president United States and he's
bragging about grabbing a woman but even
though I don't feel that he meant it
like that still I feel like you meant it
like a you play a locker room
- you guys you're fighters if I said to
you guys you know I hit it last night
sure you know do you do you think I'm an
I hit it you know no I'm I it's a
euphemism for like what remember what he
said he goes I just start kissing him
I don't happen by the [ __ ] in there and
they let you up your star he was the
billionaire Donald Trump who's like
who's going on Howard Stern right yeah
talk about how you'd [ __ ] waitresses in
LA cuz do the hotter hotter than you
would I you and I both said we have
friends we will professor some guy god I
don't know if you wanna talk like right
we both were like I don't know anybody
actually would say that we I don't
really hear I grew up in locker rooms on
in here like in the guys like us well
suddenly go and and you didn't get to
squat Lyle so then go he's a rapist no I
went that's a creepy girl very
surprising that 54% of white women voted
for him anyway that's how much they
hated Hillary but I'm just saying for a
lot of me to advocates or women who had
suffered a lot of that [ __ ] a lot of
women went oh it's go time they'd really
passed the hounds don't release the
hounds
well this is this is but this is you
know this is consequences of the
decisions of you know the white
establishment for you know a hundred
years man I mean this is like these
consequences for human bein behavior
when there are no consequences so when
you have it there Danny exuberant people
or my privilege is real man it's real
when people don't want people act like
that's not a thing male privilege is
real white privilege is real this is
real this is a thing that and we don't
realize it when we're knee-deep in it I
don't I'm a man so I look at this and I
we think the same thing with like I come
on I'm not I'm not raping a chick but
we're in the middle of a thing or a
safer part yeah the world is safely not
worried about the same things
yeah the world is a lot safer a lot
safer and a lot easier and I'm starting
to be like okay I get it that's why I
like so many times these things happen
in the news and I want to fire off a
tweet in the mail defense in a way like
there's no due process anymore and I go
let me get out of this because you know
what
never have have had to do process well
the question is the question is
everybody wants to make the world more
equitable the question is how do we do
it you know the real question is should
it be you know like we're not created
the same that's we're obviously
different well you you're done about a
hierarchy of competence so if you're
confident you know right you're a good
comic you should get stage time it's not
like you go in because now they grind
this they're going wait we got to find a
woman they're doing this they're going
there aren't enough women or gay people
or genderqueer on stage or wider whoa
whoa whoa everything funniest wins bro
and that takes years this is this art
form takes forever well I don't have a
[ __ ] what you look like a fittest that's
professional sports that's professional
yeah Hollywood's a little different no
but they're all moving in there but the
idea is let's go in and equalize not see
the thing is I wish that comedy worked
at the waist the reason why I love
sports because it's an elitist system
there is no no one cares what color you
are if you're the best athlete you can
visibly see it and you go I get why this
guy is making all the money you know
Eastern design Barragan why are they all
black yeah we get it we get it okay hold
on so like an entertainment it doesn't
work like that like listen I watched
this girl's special on Netflix this is
what everybody's talking about
everybody's going to rage in overtime
okay Han again spend again listen for me
I didn't laugh one time okay that's okay
that's her one-woman show but no but the
things I'm hearing being written about
it I read something that said it is what
was it like she was she took the chance
not to be funny okay like you know
here's my thing if I'm watching her if
I'm watching a sports sporting event and
I do shoots three for 15 in the
Champions she's not athletic he didn't
do well you assume he's athletic he
didn't do what yeah okay and it's okay
to be like what I got didn't have a good
luck done he he had off night but
everyone was watching him I'll be riding
going like oh wow the bravery to take a
chance to take those shots that he
missed a chance it's like it's like hey
maybe he would maybe the shots were wide
open he just missed them
yeah that should be okay to be like why
didn't I didn't find this funny I'm
having a struggle trying to figure out
what is our business turning into like
like what happened
like what I'm saying this take a tough
subject and the point of it is we're
supposed to try to make people laugh and
be entertaining I think that's what I
think and I think that that's changed
why do you have to worry about that I
still be funny and entertaining and
somebody's gonna be like literally
looking at the other buddy else and
being like you know all these other
white faces that you know but but that
well I think that girl's special whether
you like it or not whether she eight
dicks or it's killing it and you have a
special on Netflix I don't think it's
gonna steal any shine away from real
comics who are trying to be funny
anyone Hannah Gatsby's you know I'm
saying like yeah there's so much contact
i watch that there's a link there's a
lane for her right it's not it's not for
me it's I totally agree with you like
this especially this comedy is so
saturated right now it's like never you
know just greenlit 61 comedy specials i
watch that special i talked to you about
it and what for me I found a very
uncomfortable to watch because she's
coming after people like me but I have
to say I'm glad I watched it and I know
so so here's I was gonna say I hear
comedy special I turn into it and it's a
TED talk yeah I'd be pissed so here's
what it was
here's what it was it was it was it has
a lot of value but here's what I have to
say about it uh it was she's a comic and
Ken and she's very comfortable and very
adept at killing a room she's been doing
it a long time however she said the
comedy I can't really do comedy anymore
because it's not gonna allow me to tell
my story
now what I thought it was was a great
piece of theater right right I didn't
think it was comedy I thought it was a
great piece of theater very
uncomfortable for me I had to sit i
squirmed but I'm really glad I saw it
because I found it very inspiring
actually and with a lot of value not
comedy not comedy but great but my thing
is like I totally appreciate 100 that
sentiment and I'm looking at these
specials now from people that are my
friends like Jerrod Carmichael is one of
my best friend loves usually no but he
doesn't like comedy he doesn't you talk
to him he'll tell you that he's a smart
he's like I hate comedy so he did this
kind of sort of vulnerable in the round
talking about things in a way
that was like oh this is different I
said it was like a symposium I was like
this is a conversation with car it would
rate would draw Carmichael as opposed to
like yeah I'm done intentional cuz it's
emotional yeah it's emotional yeah I'm
from an era where I like this was like
here's this funny person dealing with a
really hard subject and they're
presenting it in a package that makes me
laugh and think we're now we're coming
to this thing where we're saying no we
don't care about that package of
entertainment or humor we just want the
vulnerability that Netflix no but I say
this though I say it's everywhere my
voice theater no that's Brooke but I say
like if I'm attic if I look at the I
have a dream speech from Martin Luther
King I could I could say the same things
about that speech but if I put it on
Netflix and labeled it a comedy special
I better [ __ ] laugh that's right
yeah I agree however center and look I
had two special would you ever I know
some people look at my spare to be like
well I didn't think that was funny but
then you at least know I was trying to
be funny right
that's what I'm saying they're trying to
make people laugh I just didn't like it
okay but if I'm Carmichael I found that
the who's the lady yes if I'm Hannah
Gatsby I wouldn't package it as a comedy
special
I don't the goal here was kind of
special that's not what this is I just
say that she didn't cool he asked cool
but then it's still like what's in the
comedy I have to say she's she's she's
kind of brilliant she's very smart but
my problem is with these people are who
are supposed to be the safeguards of
comedy my people are all these bloggers
and all these people who are writing
about comedy in a way that it has
nothing to do with comedy anymore
they've hijacked it they've taken over
this fun on a ferocity that's a great
way to put it you know that's a great
way to put it it was it with stand-up
tries but we used to do I'm gonna watch
it Whoopi Goldberg did a tragic
one-woman show yeah she's amazing
so it's like you never see Whoopi
Goldberg what what god I just an eternal
man her first special when she was
nobody knew she wasn't her name is
Whoopi Goldberg she would bring you up
laughing and then she'd [ __ ] kill you
yes is that
but what I'm saying is I think that
they're trying to say we're light as if
like being funny is somehow bad this the
whole alternative comedy movement is
like this whole idea of like if you're a
mainstream comic like you're doing
something horrible you doing something
bad like just because people are
enjoying you it's like it's a weird
thought that the desirability Eric I
thought the liability with Annette with
with this with and I guess it was it she
was very very prejudicial without trying
to be without realizing it so she goes
why are male comics angry like she was
laughing about it you have no right to
be angry essentially well well well Wow
well that's not fair at all cuz you have
no idea cuz maybe your dad beat the [ __ ]
out of your mom in front of you maybe
your dad beat the [ __ ] out of you maybe
you got raped there are a lot of reasons
I know a lot of comics who had it hard
yeah are angry and we're soaked and
shamed themselves oh it's great I know
when your dad watching you you know any
girl like where the salt who had it easy
and it was all chaos growing up but but
here's the thing though this is the time
for this to this if thing we're talking
about so like as guys we're here we're
guys and we're talking like you know
this is male privilege right here so now
we have to sit here and we have to go we
have to give women their time they're
due
this is the time for us to not have to
have anything to do with it this is just
art yes derping and it should be that's
why I appreciated her our our our I very
much appreciated what she did I think
she's brilliant
I think her one hour had had value I'm
still I'm still trying to figure it out
emotionally in my head and I'm still
trying to make sense of it one of it and
in that sense she's a huge success
because for me like my wife was I crying
and she loved it and she goes with a
post about it I go I'm still trying to
figure out how I how I feel about
because a lot of ways my one hour that
I'm about to shoot is I don't think is
it is the same thing but also a bit of a
rebuttal to this oh and it's not that
it's right-wing or left-wing but it's a
rebuttal to it and I've been spending a
lot of time thinking about you know in
this heart you know what you know what I
let me tell you what the me to movement
has done for me it has made me more
thoughtful me too
you know it's like I had jokes about
Trump
when it was first coming on when he
first was coming in office not in
defense of him but just saying like hey
it's not his fault he was the best
candidate in the Republican Party and
like just and then it came to a point
where like he won and then people were
angry and people felt uncomfortable then
I was like I can't talk about this
anymore
and then like we're so sensitive in
society right now that it's like we're
out here just trying to tell jokes like
I had this woman and - I was at the
Comedy Store and she tweeted at me I was
just working she not just economy so
it's not always gonna be good but she
tweeted this at me I would rather take
the whatever the date-rape drug is
what's the name of the movie wrong oh
gee no GHB
she said I'd rather take GHB than watch
her comedy I had a tweet ready to go
that said then you're prepared you're
perfectly ready to go [ __ ] yourself you
know I had that ready to go yeah I
didn't send it yeah and I tried to
engage with her and there's a lot of
anger out she got nasty bow out of this
yeah but my point is that makes it hard
to just want to go up and do
misogynistic sort of like fun
you know humor like you know even if
it's misdirection stuff it's like
there's no right or wrong way but now
we're out here and like this has made us
be like well you've got to be more
thoughtful about what you talk about
see that's okay you should be able to
joke about anything and my MOT my answer
to that is just because you can doesn't
mean you should that's right look man
that's a very good point and it's made
me more thoughtful too and it's yeah
it's made me more aware of my impact
because I never had any consequences do
whatever we wanted and now there's some
recourse so there was always a male
whisperer Network which was she's a
[ __ ] and you know get a job again now
when you're when you're the [ __ ] yeah
the women go you know what I don't like
being alone with that guy I think that's
good we iterated my point right now is I
have nothing wrong with this lady I
think what she did is like she got her
message out she's making people think
I'm trash and doing some right we're
talking about it we're talking about it
and I get that what and I have no
problem with her but it's like the the
people that tried there are supposed to
be the safe
are supposed to be like their their
their trash and everyone else as if
there's no value in any other kind of
common that's right brother
and there's value in every type of
comedy yes there's value in a guy but
what I'm talking about guys my last
special just I just came out with
American warrior on Showtime I was
talking about our Christians and I like
some of them are closed-minded and I can
teach people hitting me up talking about
hey man why don't you talk about Muslims
why don't you talk about this and I go
hey I'm talking about what I know yeah I
went to Catholic school my family's full
of closed-minded hateful Christians so
those are the people I'm gonna talk
about that it's not up to me to make you
feel comfortable about what I'm talking
about to frame it for you
it's for you to look at what I say agree
or disagree and laugh in the process and
I think the army the enemy is not a
category of people raised very white men
or anybody else it's ignorance its
igneous and and this is that's exactly
this is why I say like what happened
like this that whole Izzie's situation I
think it's well these things that's what
I'm saying it's like you know you're a
star you're famous hey I've been did
without first coming up in workaholics I
was with some chicks that would have
pepper-sprayed me seven years before him
you know it's like what are not doing in
this situation yeah but I feel
comfortable in my I feel comfortable in
like I can read people yeah got feel
comfortable like I know where like you
pick up on shy I pick up on like oh this
this districts crazy yeah like I don't
feel comfortable being around there
alone with this chick but now because of
everything now I'm gonna be like even if
I don't feel that wall so I have a
girlfriend so but I'm single you be out
there now because of all this I wanna be
like nah no I'm cool I don't know you
yeah you know and I you know that and
that's gonna take away from those women
who are comfortable with themselves yeah
those women who are they got wherewithal
they know how to handle themselves in a
situation they know the difference
between being being a pervert and being
like flirty you know it's like like
Geraldo had a thing about like he said
you know how many people have gotten
married from working together right they
go take that away yeah they are you know
that's gonna go away romance doc yeah
yes so it's like guys are scared you
can't let you stay away
again legislate like you said dancing so
tight you can't not legislate how we act
as human being you know what there there
will be blowback there already is
blowback and a lot of women feel the
same way I women are blowing back there
a lot of women are whoa whoa whoa
because this country is a we're always
working progress is an idea
we're always waxing and waning we can
write you know when you when you go we
had this sexual harassment seminar for
I'm Dinah pier you have to they have to
they all do it now everyone has
everything our lawyer comes in and they
talk to you about this but even up like
what we did in here was bad when you
talk to her when you talk to a lawyer
about sexual harassment that this is a
statement they always say you know what
when you see it that's not true no no
that because there's no way to define it
ya know what I'm sayin ography yes'm
court justice said I don't know how to
define it but I know it when I see it
this is true it's a true one I was very
black and white no I'm telling you but
to just sum right Rehnquist Christian a
Victoria's Secret might be considered
porn on yeah you know so what I'm saying
though is like and I feel this way about
over sensitivity to I think that when
you're super sensitive about things and
you're like you know you're on a pulpit
of like you know you know you're wrong
you're mansplaining you're this and that
I know what I see right now is you're
being you're being a little outrageous
this is why George Washington said one
of the most important virtues in society
is civility so that you can listen to
the other side and not not surround
yourself people to see the world the way
you do and give the other side the
finger we yeah this ability is the way
you share ideas yeah and you have what's
called idea sex you put I DS together
and you come up with a better solution
and civility is a very important thing
and we've lost a lot of it in the public
square man and on the main side of this
with this well stated earlier we've lost
being a gentleman correct like we've
lost this thing where like we should
treat all women with respect and love
and some women you know some women you
know when you're in bed with them I'm
just saying though but no I'm glad you
said that because what I'm saying is the
the the the journey to find out if a
chick is a freak is
where we need to be gentlemen but also
you know we're not like when we get
there it's fun we having a problem the
other thing that came to laws that
Hannah one of the biggest moments in her
life was when she got the [ __ ] beat out
of her by this straight white male
ignorant piece of [ __ ]
what I what she should she should know
is that there are a lot of straight
white male like this guy like that guy
like I'm sure you know you're not white
male but they're got a lot of straight
white males I know and then I saw if
they saw if I saw that guy beating up on
her because she's a gay woman like that
I can promise you on my [ __ ] life I
can say isn't I hate when people say
I'll be zest I
I'll tell you right now or I'm not I
would be on that [ __ ] back
trying to choke him or take his [ __ ]
the eyes out so there are a lot of dudes
that that a lot of these straight white
males who would be would come to her
defense to the majority the majority so
anyway enough of that but the point is
your points are really well together
really good point no suggestion this is
a little weird one creepy one
I've heard of extreme embalming extreme
embalming what is it
so when someone dies instead of just a
regular open casket funeral type of
thing sometimes these families know I
want to have a mic in my hand I want to
be like you know I'm saying yeah dude
this is brilliant so this guy he loves
to games those are her favorite snacks I
see those teeth you'd like to wear
slippers those socks so his family did
that dude this is dope and then this one
she like drinking scotch and beer with a
cigarette with a cigarette
that's her you know what they bomb only
up why is it only black people though
there's different ones that changes up
here where's another book oh he loved to
be superheroes what's going on
all the hate mail is gonna come now Miss
Hannah Garcia so he might be Brazilian
yeah whatever bro Berto Rican mother no
like here's I think this guy's Spanish
or Mexican how extreme bah what about
you going what die with someone it's
like yeah what are you guys you're a
porn star yeah there's only one more and
it's this guy oh it's just dressing him
in his favorite clothes I guess I think
that's a better way to go then it looks
like he was probably in a wheelchair or
something he's got that like so Hopkins
life if I was in a wheelchair I would
want to make sure I was like embalmed
like I was dunking a basketball yes like
I'm hanging on the rim like Shaq yeah
this like just some cool [ __ ] you know
what this is this is this is a sign of
the change of times this is another sign
don't you know your old stream bombing
has been around yes yeah but not like
this dress them in swag these your
Indonesia they've been doing it for
millennia you know I mean you use your
you you have them and they basically are
mummified and they sit there and they
just basically stay mama what can you
keep them at home that kind of thing you
know these you as soon as the [ __ ]
funeral over they take one burn up they
don't stay like that mummified area or
they you know you are modified you know
how bombing works yeah it's [ __ ]
great rain you of all your blood and
organs and then they fill you with an
embalming fluid yes good time okay see I
don't want people taking selfies when I
don't like I saw my grandpa bombed I was
like that ain't my grandfather yeah
oh no way I might see him I ever see my
grandpa it was all like [ __ ] up it
you know but they told me and they dress
them like [ __ ] and they're stiff
there's nothing you know what I don't
like what I'm saying when people die
like you like you know I don't see
you'll be back up when you it's like we
were talking about earlier we've known
each other a long time yeah one thing I
learned in a County business we know
each other but it's like we work at a
Super Walmart yeah you know we know
ratios each other in the breakworld
yeah yeah it's you're over in produce
I'm over here
yeah we see the Brian what's up man we
might have a conversation at the at the
enter at one of the racks that's right
that's a girl to go we don't really know
each other and it's like it's not two
major events happen to people's lives
that's when I know that I'm somebody's
friends yeah you know I haven't been
invited to a number of weddings that I
thought oh I thought I was this guy's
friend right you know tell you know
that's a you know so you know it's the
same kind of like I know you know what I
mean so it's like here we are
who knows what people I celebrate this
though I'm well I'm so down for this on
a stage yeah what a mic this is dope
what I'm trying to say was when like a
comic dies and I don't know him I'm not
going to the thing yeah I'm not gonna be
up here I do a benefit like what that
one number that one kid died Angelo no
oh man this was a kid he was like he was
on the open mic circuit he was just
about to like that's the thought
everybody had he's gonna blow up you
know and then they had all these
benefits for this stuff and I just I
just didn't go to him because I was like
I don't know yeah yeah I don't know
that's fine I didn't want to be like I
felt like you know you know phony if
you're sad junkies you know people think
I'm like you know now you know the thing
with things happening because you know
what sometimes when people die you're
not sad at all you know you don't know
here you go people die all the terrible
pass the salt know people die all the
time like damn is crazy anyways like it
should happen and I feel bad about some
of the people that just recently died
that like I did know and then it was
like damn what do you do like it really
was like yeah I'm like well I knew
Siddiqui I started with a break I
started in 2004 we were in a contest
together in Seattle we didn't say a door
could do a standing backflip at 40 you
know yeah he just passed away so I
thought I was right guy but I was like
thinking about it it made me think about
like damn am i checking in with the
people I consider my friends yeah am i
checking in with them like what would
happen if I died who would know who
would be involved it's like damn you got
to really look at your circle and be
like who's in your struggle for me it's
harder cuz I'm an only child my parents
you know my mom and my stepdad they just
moved to Spain like two years ago you
know so it's just like right now I'm
here like yeah I I'm here by myself yeah
like yeah that's what I always tell my
mom I lost my emergency contact
yeah yep you know what I mean yeah so
it's like no she kind of gotta start
that now I have a new one you know so
it's like but still you like makes they
say need home yeah they need that like
Jay Leno was saying most comics stay
married forever because that's their
base yeah you know yeah you know I feel
like I'm a better person because of
Rachel you know I feel like she's like
made me beat like I had to be more
thoughtful about my emotions and like
blowing up and like you know me I'm like
oh and here's this person this other
human being I have to deal with thoughts
and write and ideas you know that so -
yeah Jen was what maybe one more
all right listen I end on the dead
people this one I don't know if it's a
big deal but so the co-creator of
Deadpool we had tweeted out to Russell
Crowe like he wanted him to read for the
actor cable or the character cable right
the one that Josh Brolin ended a plane
and it was like the biggest movie the
summer yeah apparently Russell Crowe was
offended by it that they even offered it
to him that they wanted him to read for
it Todd do you want the part right away
yeah I guess that's the same Matthew 90
that big of a deal you don't want them
to say even though he that's like a
thing that you we want you to read for
it it's you either have it or you don't
kind of deal is that right yeah for a
big act like that you and they want you
to come and read your ideas you've seen
my body of work yeah you know what I'm
around 100 with that I'm like yeah you
want me or not yeah like who's this for
cuz he's done enough war bodies just
build name like we know what he's about
I really should make some conversation
here a movie it should be like hey we
want you to come in we want to talk to
you about this yeah how do you feel
about now I think it's just bad wording
that's also the hose also though you
know sometimes they're like why not for
a girl but they go wow if he is right
for the price to see what he's gonna
believe let's get eyes on them why'd you
read this as table and let's just see
what how how you feel when you know why
he's reading right do you know why
Russell Crowe's we've been out for a
little bit because Russell Crowe was
difficult to work with yeah and Russell
Crowe mates it seems like grandpa's old
Tom and the business went the business
when you take a seat now take a seat and
then this is a huge opportunity Deadpool
we all know is gonna be [ __ ] you
that's it Eric Griffin you're a beast on
the miles fun that wasn't fun as [ __ ]
yeah thanks you're awesome
what a fun we don't hate each other I
wanna know if your brother though piece
of [ __ ] Jason strong hey come see me
this weekend Syracuse before tally all
Syracuse I got Friday Saturday at the
funny bone coming sister
I met 240 born in Atlanta when this
weekend oh good I'm gonna be in Atlanta
I'm leaving tomorrow Matt Ryan taking
Matt rife with me don't see that dime
piece in there you know I mean and he'll
get the mothers I'll get the daughters
if he likes older women but I'm not
gonna get the daughters Rachel if you
listening and I'm in spoken Thursday
Friday Saturday spoke spoke in and then
first week of August I'm at cap city
Austin second week doused the stick is
almost sold out t fat K calm also we
just released our vintage T fat case
shirts the Metallica theme once and
Friday our collab with roots of fight
drops it's the vintage boys of summer
shirt drop it with roots of fight back
Shing air Griffin your beat shaming
alright bro sorry man I was I'm sorry
you had to send away this is a fine kid